the ocean currents that help to keep
britain's climate so mild
start 9 000 miles away in the chile seas
of antarctica
it's here that cold water sinks to the
deep and begins a long journey north
across the equator
warming along the way and helping to
even out temperatures around the planet
i joined scientists from british
antarctic survey as they monitored the
effect of melting ice
fresh water that then sits on the
surface of the ocean
slowing the downward plunge of the
currents there's a pattern of
circulation in the atlantic
where water comes in at one level and
goes out at a different level that's
called the atlantic overturning
circulation
of which the gulf stream is a major
component and it keeps western europe
warm
relatively benign climate all these
circulation patterns are interconnected
and the southern ocean around antarctic
is a key part of them
what the models we have and the
observations we have seem to indicate is
that
that circulation in the north atlantic
is slowing down it's all connected
the earth is one system and to
understand any part of it you have to
understand all of the parts
new research has zoomed in on the north
atlantic circulation
which transports heat from the tropics
to europe
already the system of currents called
amok have slowed by 15
and now at their weakest in more than a
millennium
but melting ice at both poles could slow
it by 34 to 45
by the end of the century changing our
climate
we may get more winter storms reaching
britain
we also expect that we may get more
summer heat waves in effect what you're
doing is you're
altering the maritime influence um
it'll also have impacts on um places
elsewhere other than the uk
so the u.s east coast may see colder
winters
it'll be impacted by sea level change
[Music]
in antarctica an iceberg the size of
bedfordshire has broken away from the
brunt ice shelf
it's a natural process not climate
change
but global warming is accelerating the
melt of polar ice
and that's having consequences in every
part of the planet
thomas more sky news